you're seeing the latest California
wildfire that exploded overnight in
Ventura County it forced thousands of
people from their homes the largest
power provider in California Pacific Gas
and Electric is under intense scrutiny
for its part in numerous fires last
year's devastating Paradise fire was
blamed on the company's equipment that
sent PG&E into bankruptcy
just this week two new fires may have
been caused by PG&E Jonathan Vigliotti
shows us how the utilities decision to
shut off power to millions has angered
customers and state officials meant to
save the state from deadly wildfires the
scope in size of PG&E power shutdowns is
astonishing
but for Richard strain the blackouts are
literally breathtaking collapses and
it's hard to breathe your gas strain
needs propane to keep a generator and
CPAP machine running so he can breathe
at night I can't sleep without he lives
in one of the areas that PG&E has cut
power to in recent days because of the
threat of high winds that could break
powerlines and spark fires the company
serves 16 million customers over 70,000
square miles half of that in hi fire
threat areas Deana Contreras is a
spokesperson for PG&E is this system
ready to run in a wildfire it the system
is safe this is a step that we're taking
to prevent wildfires system is safe
turned off the PG system is safe our
goal is to provide safe reliable
affordable power to our customers in
Northern California PG&E resorted to
widespread blackouts after its equipment
was blamed for several blazes including
last year's deadly camp fire in paradise
in which 86 people died while some
support the move saying it could save
lives and property relative
others are critical including California
governor Gavin Newsom who's demanding
California utilities spend five billion
dollars in improvements we've had
decades of mismanagement decades of
greed this
will not be the new normal governor news
has been a little critical lately saying
that PG&E has been asleep on the job as
wildfires have become more dangerous
are you asleep on the job we share their
governor's commitment to safety that is
our commitment to safety and we
appreciate feedback from the state from
our regulators from all legislators and
stakeholders PG&E says they're doing
accelerated safety inspections on about
50,000 transmission structures
installing more than 7,000 miles of
stronger poles and covered lines and
adding 1,300 new weather centers the
company says he doesn't know how much
future upgrades will cost but governor
Newsom told CBS News he'll fight to
prevent that cost from being passed on
to customers it's a new day of
accountability transparency
responsibility and we're going to hold
them to account in a way candidly we had
it in decades for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Santa Rosa California
well nobody wants that to be the new
normal but I don't seem to be able to
figure a way to figure it out yeah it's
must be incredibly frustrating being a
customer eugenie right now must be a
better plan